I'll brush my teeth before this so as
you can see I have a water stain on my
shirt looks like the drooled on myself
but I'll appear you have [ __ ]
perverts Oh what's going on you two now
for a lot of ladies out there that don't
know this this has to be said because
before you get into a serious
relationship I feel a lot of you girls
out there don't know this about men and
so when you see this male pattern of
behavior and you think it's weird you're
trying to change it and I'm tell you
your guts to stop it and unbeknownst to
you it is not your place to change this
about your men and if you think you're
gonna get away with it not today
[ __ ] now what I show you this
right here you're gonna know what the
[ __ ] I'm talking about what you see this
piece of fabric they look like a
Rottweiler chewed up the dick hole this
though you may not understand is your
boyfriend's favorite pair of boxers get
dog's throat ow hey every time I have
been in a serious relationship every
girl has right in my closet and tried to
throw away my favorite pair of boxers
but let me ask you something [ __ ] do you
think you are [ __ ] we just got together
coming in to throw away my [ __ ] I'm
gonna put us out right now I'm a very
simple human being but that is a point
where I will draw a line listen I get it
you can make a comment about the way I
dress about the way I chew my food about
the way my hair is done or when I sit on
your back every now and then and I
fought so hard to leave a stain on your
shirt what just me you have to
understand something
I've had these boxers longer than I've
known you these muscles are so old I had
these when I was like 280 pounds yes
they don't even fit me anymore
but listen beef boxers are not old
they're classics they are the clock that
is draped across my balls neck you know
that's my boxers money okay do you want
any idea how many years it took for me
to wear down the fabric to the point
where it feels like the breasts of a
Roman goddess huh yes the more you wear
a pair of boxers is silky it feels and
you just tried to throw away all my hard
work are you liking about this coming to
your room and just punch you right in
the vagina because that's what
like let me ask you something else it's
grape juice in a barrel just a box full
of old ass juice no [ __ ] just try to
throw this [ __ ] down drink but baby
those are all it took me years to put
that [ __ ] in there and do an effect
called thunder-thighs
erosion you think this was an accident
no it was hard work you know what you
are [ __ ] you are a thief of joy I bet
when you look at the grandkids you try
to feel that whole thing up with sand
huh evil oh and I've already prepared
for you to go up and say some stupid
[ __ ] oh did you just say what you mean
better what you just don't replace my
old boxer because newer is better or she
I never thought I would say this to you
but I am ashamed is that the type of
woman I am wait how about this then what
about the day when you get so old your
titties look like two Bologna's on a
hangnail you don't want me to suck them
no mom I get some up looking like two
deflated balloons I should chop them up
and throw them right in the garbage you
know what the word is you shallow
that's why you shallow as hell you have
to understand when boxers are new it
takes a few months for you to wear it
and why don't you understand I'll be
honest with you right now I don't want
to leave you and if it's the boxes or
you yes of course I'm a tooth the
[ __ ] boxers don't touch my [ __ ]
boxers hey what is going on you two
yes I've had a problem with people
trying to throw away my old clothes they
don't understand that it's just personal
I love it you just be throwing away my
[ __ ] without asking me huh
give me no Asian pen moved out of my
house for a reason goddamn but yes you
guys I will see you guys every Wednesday
and Sunday and I hadn't really figured
out what the theme of Wednesday is gonna
be but I'm thinking I might mix it into
something like movies are you Wednesdays
or something give me suggestions what do
you want Wednesday's block topics to be
let's hear it let's hear it let's hear
it no don't hear me and [ __ ] become
crazy because before you girls get it
girls out there don't know that the dog
about your method Oh what what'd you
just say oh you just you done did you
updated
really figured out what the FEMA one day
man and the Mateus kept enough I took
number and skating